Hey youtubers this is Charlie. Thank you so much
everyone that submitted questions for this
week's Korra Q&A.
So there's one more episode that is going
to be on Friday, this Friday
and then the week after that will be the
last two episodes. They will air together.
We also got word on the book four DVD
it's going to be released in March.
There is only commentaries listed for two
episodes.
It didn't say which but its probably gonna
be the finale. Like the very final episode
of Korra ever.
and then maybe Korra Alone. Just because it
felt like it was so important for the
story a book four.
I am totally sure I'll be giving away a
couple copies whenever that comes around.
But yeah gonna be a little while.
So let us answer some questions. Careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet. But
starting with number one. Edward asks: Who is your favorite Beifong?
I mean it used to be Toph Beifong. Easy answer.
Lin is
kinda my favorite but only when she's
with other certain characters.
Right now one of my favorite fan theories
is that she is really Mako's mother.
I don't think that's the case but she's
kinda like his surrogate mother.
Lin is a lot more fun when she's around
most the other characters but just Mako
in general.
I feel like they have something special
together. I will be real bummed if he
goes to the Earth Kingdom with Prince
Wu
after book four is over and Beifong stays
in Republic City.
I would hope that they would still stay
in touch. Lin seems like she's the kinda
person that really enjoys her peace and
quiet
but I think she gets lonely just like
everyone else. Question two
SuperThischannel asks: What made Kuvira such a monster?
I would say, you know, she started out with
good intentions and then just kinda fell down
the slippery slope
to being a tyrant. You could say that a
lot of dictators
in the history of the world had good
intentions and then just ended up doing
terrible terrible things.
Sometimes that's because they get bad
advice sometimes that's because they've
completely added out of touch with the people
they're trying to help.
And then sometimes you find out they
were lying all along and they never
wanted to help you.
they just wanted power for themselves.
Based on episode 10 it does seem like
Kuvira is just out for power.
She gave that rousing speech about taking
back Earth Kingdom land
but she said that's only the beginning. Meaning
that she probably plans to conquer the
rest of the world.
And why would you need to start calling
it the Earth Empire, if all you wanted to
do was help people.
There are still a lot of things we don't know about Kuvira. So I'm hoping she gives
us more juicy details about what's going
on
inside her head.
Question three: Mouna asks what happened
to Azula?
The show had four books to answer the
question and we still have no answer. I'm
starting to think the question will
become the new
"What happened to Zuko's mom". Yeah, that is totally
possible. They could just save it for the
comics.
I mean they explain what happened to Zuko's mom in the comics. It is funny that they
brought Grey DeLisle back to voice
Ming-Hua but they haven't really
explained what's going on with Azula.
It's possible that she did the same
thing that Toph did. Like she just kinda
went off into the wilderness and
wandered off.
Until confirmed dead just presume that
she is alive out there somewhere.
And given the speech that Toph gave about
leaving things to the younger folks.
I don't expect to see her in the finale.
They did say that they would be bringing
her back in the next comic book. The smoke and shadow comic book.
Obviously that will be a young version of Azula. So I think they'll just keep her there
in that space.
Question four Jack asks: What the hell
happened to the Kyoshi Warriors?
Have they become extinct or something?
No they are not extinct.
They'd mostly just been in the comics.
Just because we haven't seen them doesn't
mean that they've gone away.
There are just way too many things to
explain and Mike and Brian only have a
limited amount of time. So they're
focusing on all the Korra characters
not so much the Last Airbender
characters. I would just assume they are still on
on Kyoshi Island, doing fine.
Whenever Kuvira was first looking at
that big map in the first episode,
it would have been really cool if
we'd have seen Kyoshi Island on the map
somewhere.
Even just a small easter egg. I am totally cool with them not explaining a lot of
Last Airbender stuff. Just as long as
there's like a subtle turn of
phrase or a small joke.
Like the fish vendor with the picture
of Aang. Like that was the best easter egg
ever.
Question five Nikki asks: Hey Charlie, Do you think that Team Avatar will be fighting the forces of
Kuvira
or just Korra?  So you are saying like a one on one
thing like last time. No I don't think
it's going to be repeated like that. I think
they'll have a moment like that
and then Korra will - instead of fighting her - have
some other solution.
but I do think that before that happens
there will be some fighting. Like
they have Asami mechs and then they have
Kuvira's mechs so obviously those are
probably gonna throw down first.
Asami seemed so happy when she was trying
to explain that plan of hers.
She's just like "Look at my project! Look how amazing this is!"
That's why she's gonna go down as one of
my favorite Korra characters. I just love
little things about her like that.
I think that they will build some of
those mechs. I think the issue was that
president Reiko wanted spirit vine
weapons attached to them
and that was what Korra was arguing about. So I don't think that they're going to do
that
but it is possible. You could see a bunch of
flying mechs with WMDs
strapped to their backs. Question six Betty Sue asks:
What are the new inventions Asami and
Varrick are working on and how do you think
they'll be used?
Well so like I have explained, they're basically flying mechs. But I think what they are gonna do
is: they're gonna build them and then
only a couple of them will get used before Korra stops
the fight.
If you look at the diagram they can
actually fit two people inside them.
So I'm guessing one person flies another
person operates the weapons.
Since Varrick used that EMP I also think
there'll be a version of that too.
Like it won't just be the mechs there'll
be something else they're working on. And
since it is Varrick
I do think that there'll be a twist and
he'll do something kinda shady.
I would be disappointed if they'd just
completely made the character do 180 and he
became this
super nice likable guy who did
everything the right way.
I mean it's Varrick so he supposed to be
kinda of a butt. Zhu Li is the one that balances
him out
and now that she's going back to
Republic City I think he'll go back to
being the way he was before.
Maybe appreciate her just a little bit
more though. Question seven JediKnight asks:
Could there be a possibility of seeing a
montage of future avatars in the last episode of
Korra?
No I don't think they're gonna do that. They did
actually post a picture from the
sound editing booth.
They weren't super clear but this is going to
be one of the final shots of Korra.
I don't think it'll be the last shot of the
series, just because I don't think that they
would
tease that out. If anything it'll be just
the birth of the next avatar.
if she does end up dying. Really I think
what they would want to do is tie up the
big story lines.
And then leave on a ending that's ambiguous enough that it gives you some head
space to think about what might be
happening with the characters. It gives
them a future.
Without necessarily completely spelling
it out in great detail.
And even if she doesn't actually
reconnect with her past lives, I do
think we'll see a visual reference to
them,
even if it's not in the way we
traditionally see them. Question number
eight Xyalan asks:
Do you think that Bolin will end up with Opal?
That's a good question.
I do think they'll try to make it
work but Bolin seems like he wants to
be a mover star
and Opal seems like she wants to stay with
the airbenders. I don't see the two them
moving to Republic City together.
But they do have Airbender Island, so I
do think they could make it work.
I'd be really surprised if they'd gave
us a flash forward and showed us
like a Bolin-picture with a bunch of
Bolin-Opal children.
I do think that they'll end things on good terms. It seems like
they're kinda back together as of episode 10.
So you can just consider them a couple.
Everybody makes mistakes. I mean the avatar characters aren't
infallible. So it's possible they could
break up in the future,
after the series is over. Hopefully not,
you know I would like to see them
together.
Question number nine Momo Bear asks: Why have they left Kai out for the past three
episodes,
just considering he's in a relationship
with Jinora, you would think they'd mention him at
least.
You really like Kai. I think that he is really just with
the other airbenders and they haven't shown
them because they have been critical to
the stories they're telling.
It's mostly been about the Beifongs
more so than the air benders but
I do think when we come to the big final
conflict at Republic City
all the airbenders will come back to
Air Temple Island. So we'll see Kai then.
As far as we know the airbenders aren't
quite as critical to the stories as they
were in book three.
Question number ten Michelle asks: I want to know your thoughts on two things:
How do you see Mako playing out in the
finale? Do you think he'll have a bigger
role
than just babysitting Wu? Also do you
think that Korra will have her own special
moment at the end of the finale
do you think it will be more of a collaborative team effort when beating Kuvira?
So,
yeah I mean I think that Korra will have
her moment with Kuvira. It'll be like the two
of them together again. Kinda like when
they faced up the first time.
To answer your question about Mako, I do
feel like they're setting it up for him
to go with Wu and become his adviser.
That was why I think he made that
comment: "You're starting to look like the
kinda person I could go to work for."
The bummer about that, is that it would
take him away from the rest of team
Korra.
Altough to be fair - I mean if Korra is gonna
continue living, if you didn't die in the
finale -
then she'll be able to travel all over
the place, just like Aang did.
So even if Mako does go to the Earth
Kingdom, everybody else could still visit
him
and they have that high-speed magnetic
rail now too. So it's a lot quicker to
get around.
Thank you so much everyone for submitting
questions. These are always a ton of fun to do.
Just remember episode 11 is going to be
this Friday. And then the week after that on
the 19th it'll be episode 12 and 13.
Congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner you Needo Canary you win a copy of the
book 3 DVD.
Just be sure to message me on my channel
for details just because I need some shipping
information.
I will give away another copy of the DVD in
this friday's video.
So just be sure to subscribe to get that.
And if you guys haven't seen already
Amazon is having a sale on Avatar comics.
You can actually download them if you
had like a Kindle app. So you can actually read them digitally. You don't have to buy the physical
copies.
It just a quicker way to get them.
But they're super cheap. So lots of huge
stuff happening this week.
Midseason finales for Arrow and the Flash
tonight. So be sure to check back later
for those.
Right now you can actually click up hear
for on your mobile phone or on your tablet.
It's the same as links over here.
But click here for my episode 10 video
and click here for all my other avatar
bonus videos.
Thank you so much for watching. So let's all high five
I'll see you guys in a little while.